how many times do you watch something
and you say
that could not be made today that that
movie that tv show that
whatever so you know on this channel
we analyze all the woke commercials so i
thought
for a little change of pace it would be
good to look back at commercials
of days gone by and to try to figure out
which one is the least likely to be made
today which one most transgresses the
new woke standard before we get started
this video is sponsored by blinkist
blinkist brings you knowledge from
top non-fiction and podcasts students
you can learn anytime any
where we'll have more from them later
first let us begin
a very close call could have gone either
way it was
right on the line well ferguson's not
too happy with it i can tell you that
much
he's beating him like a rented mule and
the reps just
tuning him out boy where do you train
to take a beating like that he said
when's that porch gonna get painted in
that litter box
it's been three weeks three weeks and
you think i could have married don
hoffman and it wouldn't hurt for you to
say that you love me once in a while
so in initially i thought there are
actually two reasons why you couldn't
make this commercial today
the most obvious of course is this
nagging terrible wife
screaming in his face you're not you're
never allowed to say that you see
men bad women good
men can also become women which is
confusing but husband bad
dumb terrible lazy oaf wife brilliant
wonderful always charming always doing
everything right
so that's the main reason that you would
not be permitted to do such a thing
there's another reason though where you
you heard that phrase the beginning beat
him like a rented mule i don't know
i suspect peta would have something to
say about that the spca
and a number of other places so i guess
though probably the nagging wife takes
pride a place okay
next one jockey has supported legends
like general patton
there you go you're not though oh my
gosh no way to the moon
but imagine a buzzer in today's jockey
underwear
he would have planted the flag on all
the planets
[Music]
you're not mankind giving america dips
on the entire milky way that's because
jockey is quality crafted to last
longer guaranteed jockey supporting
greatness so three reasons here why you
could not make this commercial today one
because white guys are terrible so
you've got general patton general patton
oh my gosh
a speech to the third army alone would
be enough to get that guy canceled
he was a a racist whatever you know
terrible symbol of american imperialism
and that's no
babe ruth you know he was a hanging
around with hookers and doing all sorts
and he can't do that
i guess if he were hanging around with
sex workers that would be if he were sex
positive but i don't think he'd be
written that way and then the third one
was
buzz aldrin really really terrible guy
because
he didn't just spread american power
across the globe he spread
american power into outer space you're a
coward and a liar
and a chief he's got the american flag
that is a canceled symbol you're not
allowed to wave that anymore you have to
wave
the rainbow flag or like the new trans
black rainbow flag what's called the
progress flag or the blm flag or
something like that
the american flag you have to protest
and you're not allowed to have it on
sneakers
and you're not allowed to support it on
at the olympic trials or on a football
field
the broader problem is the presumption
of that
that last part is that it is good to
spread
not just america throughout the world
but even just to spread mankind
to go out and explore and conquer at the
end it says jockey supporting greatness
but greatness
is no longer valued victimhood and
grievance are valued you used to have a
greatness culture now you have a
grievance culture
and whereas greatness used to carry
social currency today it is victimhood
and and grievance and by the way even
all those glories of american greatness
they are now
reimagined to be awful terrible
oppression
crimes things that we we can never
salute
so for many reasons all together that
that commercial has to be canceled
it's halftime well clint alone i think
would get it
no he's still working in the locker room
discussing what they can do to win this
game in the second half
it's halftime in america too
people are out of work and they're
hurting they're all wondering what
they're gonna do to make a comeback
and we're all scared because this isn't
a game
the people of detroit know a little
something about this
they almost lost everything
but we all pulled together now motor
city is fighting again
i've seen a lot of tough errors a lot of
downturns in my life
times when we didn't understand each
other it seems that we've lost our heart
at times
the fog of division discord and blame
made it hard to see what lies ahead
but after those trials we all rallied
around what was right
and acted as one
because that's what we do we find a way
through tough times if we can't
find a way then we'll make one
all that matters now is what's ahead how
do we come from behind
how do we come together and how do we
win
detroit's showing us it can be done and
what's true about them
is true about all of us
[Music]
this country can't be knocked out with
one punch we get right back
up again and when we do the world's
going to hear the roar of our engines
yeah it's halftime america and our
second half's about to begin
[Music]
man how great is clint eastwood i
actually don't think this commercial
would be canceled
clint he's obviously a little more on
the republican side
he famously yelled at an empty chair at
the republican national convention in
2012.
you know the problems i guess of this
commercial
for the woke left is that it says that
america should come together and move
forward and not harp on all the terrible
things in the past
and the woke left does want to harp on
the terrible things in the past
but it is progressive and and i think in
the sense that what this commercial is
is saying is the past really doesn't
matter you know
just forget about it for right now let's
just move into the future the future's
gonna be a lot better
and that way it's kind of progressive
and so i actually i don't think that
one's gonna be canceled so i gotta pick
okay between
the two you've got the the screaming
wife no i guess the
the one that you couldn't make today is
the nagging screaming wife because you
the thing about the the
guys on the moon it would be problematic
and you'd probably have to throw in
like a you know a half filipino
like muslim transsexual [ __ ] or
something just to make it politically
correct and diverse
what the hell is this but you could you
could
generally you know there there is this
impulse
in progressivism to while they're
talking about how evil everything was in
the past and how we're in a terrible
crisis right now and everything's
miserable and we should be really
anxious
they they have a kind of optimism in the
sense that
they believe we're headed toward utopia
and the more the ark of the moral
universe is long but it bends toward
justice
so you could make that second one the
screaming life
i don't know that you could the only way
you could make that commercial now is if
if that were considered like a good
thing
you know if it were like yes you go girl
you tell that husband
yeah you get him off his lazy rear end
all right now in addition to
the old commercials that you you
couldn't make today
my producers wanted to show me some new
commercials i mean this is it's
obviously in all of these videos we've
got to take a look at the commercials
coming out
recently and they want me to guess
what about the commercial created an
uproar aroused the ire of the woke mob
and got these commercials cancelled
does it happen to you that you want to
read a book but you just don't have the
time
well instead of having to find the time
to read a whole book a lot of people are
short on time now
you can listen to all the highlights in
only 15 minutes how can you do that
blinkist lets you do it i've got my
blinkist app right here there's the uh
home page here you've got a bunch of
cool books you can check out you've got
sapiens by yuval harari that's pretty
cool
lots of other books and we're talking
about bite-sized books right so they've
got
the best insights from 4 500 more than 4
500 nonfiction books
and you can just read it or you can
listen to it in 15 minutes 16 minutes
you really get all this stuff
they also have shortcasts right now
shortcasts there's a million podcasts
out there i should know i host three of
them
and so sometimes people need to truncate
that information a little bit
shortcasts can help you do it right now
the first 100 people to go to
blinkist.com
knowles are going to get unlimited
access for one
week to try out blinkist you'll also get
25
off if you want the full membership that
is a seven day trial completely free you
can cancel at any time
during that period go check out blinkist
today so
they pulled a couple of these let's take
a look
i'm felipe khan and i created the camera
phone
i'm ray kurzweil i gave your words a
voice
i created the ability to share video we
turned your smartphone into a musical
genius
and i turned it into a bank i created
instagram
i created the first text message we
created words with friends
and we created a better way to buy a
smartphone any phone
any carrier and all of their plans with
lots of unbiased advice
because it's all white guys right it's
got to be is that is that the answer
here we go six sexist super bowl ads
okay so it's i was half right the guys
part is why it was bad
they didn't talk about how it was all
white guys though i'm frankly shocked by
that because it was it's all white dudes
in the
in the ads who are saying i invented
this i invented that i just
statistically that's just the way it
worked out
and so you you'd think they'd say it's
all it's because of white supremacy or
something but no
they left that part out of the criticism
it's just that it's sexist because
there's no women the only women come in
at the end okay
all right i'm gonna take half credit for
that wrong and i bet by the way that the
woke
the woke people were also upset by it
but okay i'll take half credit what's
the next one
[Music]
clean enough
all right so there's two ways we could
go on this both would irritate
the the modern left i think one is
that men are not just automatically
expected to clean you know they should
of course they should be cleaning the
house and cleaning all the dishes and
cooking all the food that's
why how dare you suggest that husbands
and wives have different roles in the
household now that's awful
so it could be that but what i'm more
leaning toward is that the left
really hates the idea of seduction this
is why they say that baby it's cold
outside is about rape because they're
illiterate is why they
think that but because they have no idea
that the way that men and women interact
historically and naturally is
a little bit of a game you know a little
flirtation a little seduction
that's a men sort of chase the women the
women
sort of modestly resist and then you
know who knows
maybe they kiss at the end as they do in
the end of this commercial but for the
the left today
the way men and women are supposed to
react is that if you want to go on a
date or maybe smooch a little bit up at
lovers point
you need to get uh like a notary there
to say let's just have like a 20 page
contract
it says i formally agree to let this man
hold my hand
and he can kiss me seven times but but
if he tries to round second you know
that
we're not going to do that and okay stan
initial here and sign on page 52.
and now we have a really formal
relationship okay is that cool south
park made fun of this
in the pc principal episodes where the
the pc principal has to walk around
the frat house and collect consent forms
after the guys hook up at night well
barker did you perform cunnilingus
there's a different release form bro
so it's one of those two i think maybe
i'm just missing something i'm going to
lean
that it's the latter it's the issue of
seduction
and consent and arousal procter gamble
attempted to appeal to women in its
reimagining of mr clean as a sex symbol
but the spot oh it was my first guess
damn man i should have stuck with that
the spot played into the idea that it
isn't typical for a man to clean
and those that do should be praised or
rewarded with sex okay all right well
hey
ah man because i did go with the latter
so i want half credit again
i know you're supposed to win or lose
but my gut
was right and then i talked myself out
of it i went i went a little bit too far
but i'm sure they were bothered
by seduction as well please post other
problematic
lib triggering commercials in the
comment section we'll see you next time
[Music]
you